друзі тотальний контроль банкової над
інформацією в Україні призвів вже до
того що державний телеканал Рада не
соромиться поширювати відверто брехню
днями вони опублікували два ролики про
європейську і євроатлантичну інтеграцію
і це ніщо інше як портал у паралельну
реальність виявляється угоду про
асоціацію підписав не Порошенко у 14-му
році а Зеленський під час 24-го саміту
України ЄС автори феєричного ролика
радісно рапортують що Верховна Рада вже
ухвалила євроінтеграційні закони в
рамках семи вимог ЄС і маніпулятивно при
цьому перераховують сім умов так наче
всі вони вже виконані також
стверджується що ми виконали
72%
євроінтеграційних завдань але на
72% виконана тільки угода асоціацію яку
ми виконуємо з 2014 року а угода - це за
ледве чверть домашньої роботи яка
передбачена для вступу в Європейський
союз Ну і два слова про систему
моніторингу пульсу води коли я як
віце-прем'єрка створювала її за своєю
каденції в уряді то ми уявити собі не
могли що вона має передбачати ймовірне
погіршення показників А за три роки
урядування урядів Зеленського у багатьох
реформах На жаль ми відкотилися далеко
назад згадайте хоча б децентралізацію
реформу держслужби чи публічні закупівлі
і система на жаль не показує цих проблем
Тому 72% - це без урахування дров яких
наламали після
2019-го ну але ж про погане в бровурному
сюжеті не говорять А упиваються
результатами безвідповідального піару
який привчає людей сприймати
Європейський союз як дійну корову голос
за кадром радо сповіщає що 40% українців
вірять у те що Україна стане членом
Європейського Союзу протягом одного-двох
років і через два роки коли дива не
станеться а його на жаль не станеться ці
40% можуть опинитися серед євроскептиків
і сварити ЄС на чому світ стоїть за те
що
Європейський Союз не виконав порожню
обіцянку шмигеля і стефанчука ролик про
НАТО теж сповнений чудесі тут автори
знову загубили купу років і ведуть
літочислення відображення Зеленського
президентом щоправда є таке згадка про
початок взаємин між Україною та нато у
92-му році і про 2014 рік Коли уряд
визнав євроатлантичну інтеграцію
пріоритету ані слова про Партнерство
заради миру чи хартію про особливе
партнерство
запроваджено 300 натівських експертів
армія отримала та освоїла сучасне
озброєння танки нового покоління
артилерію системи ппу irisp на Samsung
Patriot та інші проте що у 19-му
натовські реформи були насправді
зупинені як наприклад харчування
військових ні слова Нині ж впровадження
натовських стандартів відтермінували до
кінця воєнного стану за досягнення
подаються спільні з НАТО навчання які
нагадаю відбувалися що навіть за Кучми і
передана партнерами зброя Ну хіба ж не
соромно перераховуються якихось сім
завдань які Україна буцімто має виконати
для членства в НАТО але я ніколи ніде не
бачила такого трошки дивного списку Ну
що наприклад означає розвиток лінії
комунікацій думаю що автори і самі не в
курсі у глядача ради має скластися
враження що для повного щастя нам треба
ще зовсім трішечки виключно реформа СБУ
реалізації реформи с яке передбачає
створення повноцінної євроатлантичної
системи безпеки але це теж неправда бо
ця реформа лише частина роботи яку нам
треба ще зробити Ну і насамкінець голос
за кадром співає стару медведчуківську
пісню про референдум на якому українців
у тисячне запитають Чи треба нам НАТО
остаточне рішення буде за результатами
всеукраїнського референдуму на наша
війна ще не дала однозначної відповіді
на це питання
[музика]